FBI director Christopher Rea says
Americans can feel confident in the
election results this November we spoke
with director ray yesterday at the
bureau's headquarters in Washington for
an interview you'll see only on CBS News
the director has never sat down for an
extended interview like this before and
we first asked him about that anonymous
New York Times opinion piece that
described a White House in turmoil the
president has said that he wants the
Attorney General to investigate who
wrote that anonymous New York Times
op-ed do you believe as the President
does that this is an issue of national
security
well first off I can tell you I didn't
write it I didn't have anything to do
with it
second I would tell you that we're not
really in the practice of confirming or
discussing whether we're going to be
conducting a particular investigation I
would tell you that we're going to make
decisions about that kind of thing based
on all the factors we normally do which
is whether or not we have sufficient
evidence of federal crime you said you
did not write the Maritimes out that I
know that you have denied that but but I
want to ask you about the content it
described the president's leadership
style is quote impetuous adversarial
petty and ineffective it said that the
root of the president's promises quote a
morality does that sound like the
president you know I try very hard to
make sure that my relationship with the
president is a professional one and
beyond that I'm not going to really be
weigh in on opinions especially
anonymously expressed opinions I can
tell you that there are lots of ways for
people to express their views and their
disagreements for me the idea of doing
it through an anonymous op-ed is about
the furthest thing from my mind let me
turn now to Russia and its malign
activities when Vladimir Putin said that
Russia has never interfered and is not
going to interfere in American affairs
including the election process was he
lying well again I'm not going to accuse
somebody of lying I'll just say that
that doesn't jibe with our read of the
evidence and we're pretty confident in
our read what is Russia doing to disrupt
the midterms that are now just about 60
days away so what we're seeing now
is a continuation of the what we call
the malign foreign influence efforts
what they do is so both inaccurate
information disinformation it's the kind
of information warfare and then
propaganda exaggerated half-truths
distortions why are we letting this
happen why are we letting Russia and do
this we have the greatest law
enforcement agency in the world the FBI
we have the most powerful tech companies
in the world why are we allowing Russia
to do this I don't view us as allowing
them to do anything
I think we're countering it we are
working hard to counter it how are we
effectively all fighting back well in
some cases we have law enforcement
investigations that lead to charges in
some cases we have steps that the
technology companies can take themselves
and some cases were raising awareness
because the best defense against
disinformation and propaganda is
accurate information so come November
can Americans be confident that it was a
fair election I think Americans can have
confidence in our election system
now despite headlines about Russian
meddling the FBI director says China is
actually the single biggest threat to
Americans so we'll find out why in our
next hour as we share more of our
wide-ranging interview with Christopher
Rae about the integrity and the hard
work of the 37,000 people that work at
the FBI as you said he very seldom he
never sits down looking forward to your
next part